Bonjour,  curieuses et curieux ! Bienvenue
dans ce deuxième mini Zeste de Sciences
toujours depuis chez moi,  mais ce n'est
pas ça qui va m'empêcher de prendre
quelques minutes pour vous parler de
science et comme vous allez le voir pour
vous permettre de vous envoler un peu.
Allez,  c'est parti !
Vous l'avez compris,  aujourd'hui je vais
vous parler de drones,  ces petits engins
qui sont de plus en plus présents dans
nos vies,  y compris sous les sapins de Noël
et qui nous permettent de prendre
un peu de hauteur pour faire de magnifiques images.
Le problème c'est que c'est une hécatombe .
Un drone laissé entre les
mains d'un oncle inexpérimenté a une
durée de vie de l'ordre de 10 minutes,  au mieux.
Mais,  Tonton,  j'avais dit la manette vers le bas, c'est pas compliqué, le bas !
C'est pour éviter ce genre de mésaventure
que des chercheurs
grenoblois tentent de rendre les drones
plus faciles à manier, plus sûrs,  et même à
terme autonomes,  c'est-à-dire capables par
exemple de nous livrer des colis sans
être directement pilotés par quelqu'un.
Mais pour ça il faut que les drones soient
capables de se déplacer sans se perdre et
surtout sans percuter tous ceux qu'il
croisent.
Contrairement aux drones de tonton donc.
Alors comment on fait ?  eh bien on a
surtout eu recours aux mathématiques.
Les chercheurs développent des
algorithmes permettant aux drones
d'identifier les obstacles et de les
éviter le plus rapidement possible
Pour cela les drones sont équipés de
caméras produisant une image
stéréoscopique,
c'est à dire réalisées par deux capteurs
filmant la même scène à partir de deux
points différents et grâce à cette image
on arrive à avoir de la profondeur et
estimer la distance aux obstacles.
Ensuite on planifie la navigation du
drone d'un point A à un point B en
choisissant la trajectoire qui est la
meilleure par rapport à notre objectif :
Aller le plus vite possible ou choisir
la sécurité en passant plus loin des
obstacles par exemple. Finalement cela va
dépendre de ce qu'on a à transporter.
Non, Tonton,  je m'en fous que tu développes le
protocole de trajectoire sécurisée,  tu
n'utilises pas le drone pour transporter
la boîte d'oeufs.
Et pour effectuer un maximum de tests
affiner les algorithmes et
optimiser les trajectoires
les chercheurs ont créé des simulateurs
virtuels pour drones. L'avantage c'est
que ça permet d'obtenir des statistiques
en simulant un très grand nombre d'heures
de vol et de parcours différents,  ce
qui serait quasiment impossible dans le
monde réel, à moins de posséder la flotte de drones de Star Wars.
Non,  désolé,  vous vous êtes trompé d'adresse.
Ensuite,  on met les drones en situation
sur un parcours bien réel en labo pour
vérifier que ça marche aussi bien en vrai
et tout ça peut avoir des
applications qui vont bien au-delà de la
simple livraison de colis.
Les drones autonome pourraient être utiles
pour repérer des parasites dans les
cultures par exemple ou encore pour
inspecter des ponts,  des centrales
nucléaires à la recherche de fissures et
un jour on pourra même transporter des
personnes grâce à des flottilles de
quelques drones capables de coopérer.
Voilà qui serait drôlement bien !
Voilà, c'est tout pour ce mini zeste, si ça vous a
intéressés,  vous pouvez aller voir le
reportage complet sur la chaîne du CNRS,
je vous mets le lien de la vidéo et je
vous dis à très bientôt. N'oubliez pas de
liker, de partager et vous abonner
ce serait dronement  bien